[Music]
chuck
yes i've come to shed some more light
on that which is mysterious in this
world yes yes
the stuff you thought you knew but you
didn't what you thought you did so i
just thought i'd talk about sonic booms
okay what do you think i love that
nobody doesn't love a sonic move nobody
does
yeah that's one it's one of the best
most popular video games that's sonic
that's sonic that's sonic i tell you
that hedgehog is something
else so we can talk about sonic boom so
here you go ready so let's take a
airplane
that's a good good choice here and
generally
airplanes make noise and so you'll hear
the noise and you'll look up
and you see the plane coming right and
then receding
all right the fact that you heard the
plane
and looked up and then you see it
approaching
means the sound got to you ahead of the
plane
okay yes right the plane is not where
you are yet it's it's down
it is down it's down down the road a bit
right
so you hear it so the sound is going at
the speed of sound
and in regular air they call it 700
miles an hour
some it's around there 700 miles an hour
and the plane is still in like what four
or something
yeah frames 500 miles an hour so
the sound is emanating in front of the
plane
relative to the plane at 200 miles an
hour
nice okay all right not a problem no
this is very easy we can this is not
hard to understand all right so let's
ask the question because
by the way this 700 miles an hour is the
speed of sound in air
and typical sort of sea level type air
all right that's the speed of sound now
suppose the plane
flew a little faster let's let it go
600 miles an hour okay all right well
the sound going in front of it is now
moving front at only 100 miles an hour
faster
right because it's it's not going to
increase because it's the speed of sound
down in air okay so what that means is
the plane will be a little closer to you
before you notice that it's there right
okay because it didn't get it didn't
have a chance to get too far ahead
all right because the plane is like
right right coming up behind it but it's
still
moving away from it at 100 miles an hour
that's still pretty fast okay that's
that's fast
how about 650 miles an hour so now
wait a minute now it's only okay how
about 680 miles an hour
690. wait a minute
what happens if you go 700 miles an hour
what happens to the sound you're trying
to emit in front of you
well you can't it's right with you it's
right with you
okay it is right with you so here's the
sound you're trying to push forward
and it's moving forward it's 700 miles
an hour but so are you
so that plane approaches you
you don't even know it's there you don't
even know to turn around and notice it
right until it is directly overhead
and then the sound from the the the
sound hits you
and the light from the plane hits you
and there you are you say oh there's a
plane overhead
right well it's right there above you
right let's keep going
let's let's not stop there now have a go
750 miles an hour
800 miles an hour oh by the way we have
words for this if you know the speed of
sound
mach 1. nice so now
you have punched through this
quote sound barrier it's not really a
barrier but we used to think it was one
you punch through and now the sound
lags behind right all right so now the
faster you go
beyond mach 1 mach 2 would be how fast
twice the speed of sound twice the speed
of sound so fourteen hundred fifteen
if you go twice as fast then you
are leaving the sound behind you
right and all the sound that you are
making
is now snow plowed
into this cone
that comes out away from your vessel so
it's like your plane made a wake
of nothing that is being filled with the
sound that you left behind
correct and on the edge of that is
all the sound that would have spread out
through space
ahead of you and now it's all
compressed behind you
oh and so now that plane flies overhead
you don't know it's there right as a
matter of fact you won't know it's there
because
it it didn't make a sound it didn't
[Laughter]
brilliant chuckles you're a fast study
there yeah so
so there it is directly overhead you
don't even know to look up
right and it and it go because it's well
ahead
of the sound it's making so where's the
sound it's making well it's way behind
and it's all been snow plowed into this
wall of sound moving forward at
the speed of sound so the plane is now
downstream from you and you say hmm
that's odd
that didn't make a sound bam
the sonic boom hits you it's oh it's
all the it's like the like the
big ball of sound it's a wall of sound
it's a wall of sound
it's compressed because the plane
left it behind and all the sound that it
would have made that you would have
heard ahead of it is
now all behind it in a wall and it all
got plowed
into itself that as it passes over you
is a sonic boom
oh man and the higher up the plane is
the more
delayed that is the sonic boom you'll
come up here sonic boom look up where's
the play it was way
down way downstream
now so turns out anything that goes
faster than sound will make a sonic boom
okay so uh it turns out a whip
the crack of a whip okay is the tip of
the whip
moving faster than the speed of sound oh
sweet it's a mini sonic boom we used to
do in the locker room you get a like a
rat tail a rat with a towel
with a towel so the sonic boom comes
about
so the the the the material this would
be true with a whip
as well as it flings forward and you you
start retracting it
before it fully flings forward and the
rapid change of direction there
is the thing moving just faster than the
speed of sound and you hear a crack
it's very small it's a sonic crack i
guess
not a sonic boom so so that's what a
sonic boom is
and i love me some sonic booms but um we
you know we had
the no we didn't we've never had a
commercial
a commercial supersonic plane in the
united states
but europe did and you know what that
was uh that french plane
the french plane yeah the concord sst
good and that was a collaboration i
think with england and so it would fly
to london and to paris to new york
but we didn't have one of those planes
right
we didn't have we so how we going to
compete with that here's what we do we
say
we don't like sonic booms over our
residences so if you want to fly your
plane over continental united states
you have to fly subsonic well what the
point what's the point of that
right okay so you didn't have these
planes going to la they all went to new
york basically
right and uh and i would have been great
if we can all
fly supersonically so the concern was
you're having a nice peaceful afternoon
a picnic and then sonic booms are just
coming across
i think the novelty would probably wear
off quickly
is my sense of this now a quick little
story before we end
there's the salisbury cathedral this i i
think this is a true
story i read about it long ago but i
haven't seen more written about it so i
don't know
maybe it's apocryphal the salisbury
cathedral one of the oldest
cathedrals in the world has one of the
oldest
clocks in the world and i visited that
when i visited
stonehenge when i was a kid because the
stonehenge is in the salisbury plains
of southwest england so anyhow
the royal air force it's a very
underpopulated area so the royal air
force was doing maneuvers there and
there were sonic booms that they were
making all the time
conservatives were worried conservators
were worried that these sonic booms
would jiggle the cathedral and
and damage it okay so we got some
acoustic engineers that did some
measurements
and sure enough there's serious sonic
boom energy coming into the
cathedral and then someone said gee i
wonder how much vibration comes
from lower c on their organ
when they're pipe working so they tested
the low notes on the pipe organ
and it was more energetic than the sonic
booms coming across and i think
so that was the end of that conversation
right there okay
now it could be apocryphal but it's a
fun story what it means is just in
general
if you think something is causing
something look for anything else
that could swamp that effect and if you
find something that does then
formulate another question so now when
the sonic boom of
a meteor coming into uh our
atmosphere that's why you'll never know
the people say oh look here it comes no
you don't you don't know
until it's too late until it already
hits so is it the boom
that is breaking windows or is it the
movement of air
itself because it's just it's the same
thing it's the same thing it's a shock
wave
it's still a shock wave it's a shock
wave that's correct and you know
something else
cool okay okay uh you know the speed of
light
drops when it goes into transparent
solid materials
so speed of light is lower in glass it's
even lower in diamond
right okay now suppose you have a
particle
that you send through that material that
goes faster than the speed of light
because you can do that there's no rule
against it all right it's not my fault
the light is slow
that's not my fault i'm obeying einstein
i don't care that we're in glass
or in diamond or in water okay so
it turns out when particles do that they
make a kind of
sonic boom of their own but it's not
sonic it's light
a light boom yeah it's a light boom oh
it's a light boom well that sounds
delightful
and so it's a similar phenomenon but
it's happening sort of
electromagnetically
and it and admits its own kind of
radiation for having done so
so it's it's a gen it's a more general
phenomenon
and a principle shock waves it's all
part of the same
discussion of going faster than the
medium wants you to go
and there you have it that's very cool
well you know a light boom
you know in production there's a stand
that you hang a light on
[Laughter]
okay so that that's about it i'm just
talking
i'm all about it man that was really
cool like sonic booms
all right dude all right man this has
been star talk explainer
we'll catch you looking up
[Music]
you